[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
Greg Alba and my name is John Humphrey
in between all the comic-con stuff we
found time to watch Dunkirk on
Christopher Nolan's latest film his
first film based on a true event a
historical war drama even though it has
a ninety-eight percent on Rotten
Tomatoes or something like that like I
dare to it's an attending 90th you know
that highly rated I'm finding this film
to be quite debatable amongst every
circle I'm running in that has seen this
movie I can definitely see I this is
dough yeah if I suppose something about
this film where I think there's enough
for everybody to plan and go yeah that's
really good and there are a couple
things that are really divisive that are
going to come down to you as a viewer I
feel like we do want to make it clear we
did not actually catch this film on IMAX
which was a bummer because we saw 10
minutes of this on IMAX before we went
to go see Glasgow Island we were like
this is the way to do it and we had our
tickets but it was at the same time
during like when comic-con trailers are
dropping a time we bought them we didn't
realize oh that's right Comic Cons
rolling around so really we gotta be
around for that they're gonna watch it
later
probably sometime next week or two weeks
from now no one IMAX knowledge just be
for us yeah yeah just keep that in mind
yeah keep that in mind I feel like I
would probably really even love this
film more if I did watch it in IMAX so
this movie is to me is really about all
the technical levels of the directing
Department of the filmmaking department
not so much to me about the story but
then that's where debates come in we'll
get into that later so right now let's
just go over the things that we really
do strongly agree on the tone of this
film one thing I kept asking myself when
I saw the trailers for this and seeing
that it was a pg-13 film and I loved
Nolan films I do I was thinking though
what will be different about this
specific war drama that he's doing and
there's plenty to be found different
about this and keep in mind too the
pg-13 rating it doesn't make the film
any less effect
what it is yeah okay I could see how
this is pg-13 this isn't a movie you're
going to sit around thinking like ah
they'd only made it rated R like you
don't ya think about it I didn't yeah
this film throws you right into Dunkirk
it goes right into the situation
immediately right out on the mall yeah
it's a gloomy situation and the tone of
this film was one of the more unique
aspects to it it's a really haunting
tone rather menacing like you said it's
very immediate even though that some
does some that I can see it kind of
irritates some people and at first it
was very difficult for me to readjust to
he does kind of that Tarantino thing and
no one's sort of done it before with
other films you know people might think
of like memento or prestige in some
areas where he hops around to different
times you'll see an event happen and
then suddenly you're you're in a scene
that takes place before that event
you're not being cold that with any
subtitle or text or something like that
to make it pitch perfect clear and
there's no real heads-up that's going to
be doing that you got to catch on real
soon that if you're if your point of
view is from the beach then you're in
one story point of view is from the area
of endeavor sorry and if your point of
view is on a CR that it's a different
story that's whenever you get confusing
because this whole place is all on the
beach area it's not as easy to pick up
on because it's not like you're changing
so many different looking locations you
do have to pay attention to the weather
yes it is a lot of the time keep your
eye out for subtlety catch that when you
jump to a different storyline or a
different set of characters you're
focusing on the time is change yes and
despite it being a war movie that's not
r-rated in terms of its violence it's
unnecessary because it's not exactly
people are getting shot the whole time
we had stood in a battle to rescue the
rescue they're trying to get the
soldiers off the beach and back data to
those explosions that happens there's a
lot of drowning situations that occur in
this film and that all feels very real
what no one does so well in this film is
he puts you into this perspective of
these people one comment I made it John
when the credits were rolling was it
kind of reminded me of how when Mel
Gibson does these period pieces he pays
attention to the little details of
violent things that can occur there's
one scene where they're just climbing a
rope ladder these soldiers and even no
one takes the time to make that very
complex
yeah you were like you get caught it it
early you realize the incidental
difficulties the movies you have we
brush past in pretty much every city way
every situation tale like the harshest
conditions you can think of what could
go wrong here and it's applied not in an
overbearing like loud destination way
but in a way that feels very lived in
and it makes you go oh like I feel like
the entire point of this movie is to is
to kind of try to transcribe what it was
like to be on the ground you know yeah
be with these people in this situation
yeah and those little touches do so much
to drive that home because those are the
things actually make it a bit relatable
you know absolutely even little touches
there's like a character in it where at
one point two characters are having a
disagreement and this one character he
actually only gets pushed they fold
their falls far down some stairs at
first it's like okay whatever he's got
he just fell a little bit like a small
flight of stairs but he hits his head on
something slices open the back of his
head this isn't even during a battle
moment this is but a little touches like
that like okay based off where they are
and then if you were to fall on sir
something like this could happen that
was all very interesting to me and while
the time lapse stuff can be confusing
it's if you if you're willing to adjust
to it it does it is very effective I
knew about it going in and you didn't
and I feel like if you know about it
going in it helps oh yeah I don't know
it's because there are certain things
that you might be caught off-guard with
you might be confused with and even
knowing it myself there were times where
I even had to kind of put everything
back into place yeah because this film
to me it sort of plays out like you know
a long time ago I remember saying I
think it was to us at I was like I don't
want to do a movie where the whole thing
is just one long action scene and then
there's stories in between the action
but it's all just about the action scene
and to me this plays out like one long
action sequence oh yeah from beginning
to end it's like one long action
sequence that takes the time to slow
down but even it's just dialogue scenes
and there's not much dialogue in this
film the only very incidental yeah but
even in those scenes it's a very tense
experience it's a very suspenseful
experience because of the danger
situation and one thing too that I
really appreciate about it was yeah I
mean the enemy in this situation is the
Nazis but you never even see the Nazi
you don't ever cut to what they're doing
it's like they're
serious and that makes them kind of
scary the villain of the film is the
situation as the conditions are in
design the time and the Nazis reefs
which you never actually see the Nazi
soldiers and even yeah you all know
whether a machine yeah little planes you
see you know ships and things you don't
get a point of view on the enemy and
that puts you right in with you know the
people that you're following yeah and I
feel like one thing a lot of people are
probably talking about because we have
an actual I'll be really seen of the
Rotten Tomatoes consensus on it I feel
like the main thing that people are
probably gonna be talking about a lot
too is uh like all dogfighting that yeah
he's a aerial dogfight aerial dogfights
yeah the the thing that Tom Hardy's main
character is involved with the entire
time replay Bane yeah Krishna likes to
put Tom Arnie the masked man is also
this is his whole performance a shot in
an hour he's easy
he's very high and he's gonna be a high
and home base covered up it's all the
eye eyes and body language man so the
battle sequences the tone the pacing the
shots of the zone cinematography is all
on a masterful scale and the tension you
know like I play attention and release
yeah oh absolutely
I think the big debate that I hear
people talking about is the term lack of
character now there's a flip side to all
this because I saw some cons with it I
don't know doesn't one of my first
things I was telling you when the movie
was done and then you said some things
to me that made me go well actually
you've got a good point about that this
film doesn't really have character in a
certain perspective it's one of those
things where there's not a lot of
dialogue you don't really learn much
about these soldiers you don't have any
of the cliche type oh girl back home
girl back home I guy who has a baby
along the way or anything like that the
soldiers bonding with each other type of
situation because these characters are
all strangers and the situation is so
immediate into time for him it's taking
place and while I did feel I could have
used more character when I thought about
it later on after talking with you and
then reflecting on the movie I was like
well these guys we really talked about
anything do they stop the situation
they're in right now yeah I'm not going
to take the time to have you
conversation I understand why you would
miss
character latch on to but makes it
easier to care about the issue Asians
are in these soldiers yeah
totally and I think part of what makes
this war movie particularly special
kinda is the fact that that's not there
I understand how people would miss it
definitely but I didn't find myself
missing it you know you're cutting back
and forth between a lot of situations
and because the movie is spending so
much time making it feel like you're
there and you're just kind of there and
everything feels incidental it feels
very natural and that to me turned into
a very affecting thing there aren't any
like cutaways to people in offices
plotting you know plans of attack and
stuff like that you you only get the
position of the grunts you get the dudes
fighting in the air the dudes trying to
escape on ships and then the dudes on
the beach that kind of translates the
slog like that stuff that's not the
movies about this situation yeah I know
and I guess the other thing to why this
became less of a problem for me because
this was an immediate problem for me
when the movie was done when I look back
on the film it became less of a problem
for me because I really feel that the
actors in the film provided a full
backstory for all their characters you
can feel these are fully fleshed out
performances so maybe the writing and
the dialogue doesn't cover their
backstory doesn't really have exposition
- for you to really lean on - to have
have you feel that's personal investment
in these characters at the same time you
can still feel these actors provided
fully fleshed characters you can see it
in the eyes you can see it in the way
they respond to situations a lot of this
is choice a lot of situations as
characters get into is how will I make a
choice here and in some ways they're
kind of like avatars for the audience
like reset being in the situation with
them you're kind of just feeling it
through your own emotions of how you
might respond to it so the characters
are kind of other sort of avatars in a
way that's the point I took away from
the the way the experience hit me well
the storytelling of the movie is in
these little moments and isn't watching
people make decisions and kind of try
and read each other yeah and figure out
how to work together and and when to
object and all that sort of stuff
it's not a war movie that has a lot of
the traditional kinds of heroism it's
not like oh we won this battle it's like
little things that get turned into the
things that pull you through
yeah sure and every every story has
those
you know character every major character
kind of gets a moment of significance of
some kind absolutely like I felt like
the two characters who really got to
have a little more character to them I
guess like who the main character of II
is this soldier named Tommy who doesn't
really speak much in the film as whole
goal is just to keep trying to find ways
to get off Dunkirk
everyone in this movie is a body
language performance and I feel like the
characters you got to know better are
like Kenneth Branagh knows character but
especially Marth Rylands his characters
he was probably the standout performance
to me he's a fantastic actor to begin
with but he's the only one where you you
got to see a little bit more into how he
feels and view things and stuff well
yeah because I mean he's got a different
kind of story he's with two kids for a
lot of yeah for a lot of the runtime and
so you know it's just a different
situation than most everybody else in
the movies and that's another kind of
thing I liked about the story he chose
to tell there's one very solitary story
which is Tom Hardy story then there's
one story where you have a lot of
changing groups of people and a lot of
characters that you kind of know which
is the the mole the Beach story there a
lot of characters Netzer and then you
have this one which is kind of a nice
balance of a contained cast and it
contains yeah it's not too isolated it's
not too huge and it's about what the
people at home were doing to you
absolutely and also you know could you
shadow Harry frickin style yeah killed
it thank you time whirling he's like he
did the audition and he had it and then
I saw the movie I was like I get it yeah
yes I see what did me disconnect map
yeah you can really I saw the carpool
karaoke with Harry Styles oh I love this
guy's personality is so fun then you see
him in this movie he doesn't even have
that much dialogue but like I said every
character here you can feel the actors
provided a lot of background for them
before they got in front of the camera
and I feel like Harry Styles did the
same exact thing they all seem like real
people that was a thing it's like the
same shot like a mockumentary by any
means but do it really knows how real it
feels very real and the way the tension
plays out is fantastic and the sound
design is amazing in this and a big
contribution of that is also Hans
Zimmer's score yeah this is one of the
best scores I feel he's ever done I know
he does like pretty much all in Nolan's
films this one though specifically I
think
absolutely one of his best even if this
movie gets gypped unlike cinematography
and sound design and I get all those
things yeah it wasn't you cannot jib
this movie autism using it yeah yeah I
mean it's it's a huge part of the mood
in the tent yeah movie and I like that
no one seems to choose motifs and the
motif of the ticking the clock the
stopwatch is terrific for this movie
because the whole movie is sort of about
time or you know it's one of the major
themes is time and everybody's on a
different timeline and you get to see
how the time affects everybody and that
choice is just sonically evocative and
it also makes sense in the story and
there are also things later on where
they bring in it although it sound like
since like static you know static noises
I feel like Nolan films pretty much all
of them work better with a second or
third viewing and I make this'll
definitely even if you love the movie
the first time you watch it like
everyone references The Dark Knight even
if you love the dark grab the first time
you watch it probably even better the
second third time you watch it yeah yeah
yeah and I feel that way with most of
his films most of his films tend to play
out that way for me specifically and I
think dunker is meant to be seen on IMAX
and so this review is coming from people
who did not see it on IMAX just yet but
even without seeing on IMAX I feel like
just watching it on a regular screen I
would get more from it and appreciate
and understand it more definitely and
it's constructed I feel like when I
watch is right now I really like it if I
watch an IMAX I'm probably gonna go I
love this movie that yeah I mean in an
odd way I'm there with you oh yeah you
know it's like I really enjoyed this I
got a lot out of this the first time I
feel like and I was really pleased to
see a visual story about action yeah you
know like that's that's partly why all
the gimmicks of this movie work for me
is because you know it's kind of classic
and that way to me I think it'll
definitely come together IMAX both for
the scope because just having seen those
first couple minutes you know in the
full frame I was overwhelmed you know
the first time and I know it's hard to
watch this movie at time to be like I
just know it I know it like on Iran yeah
front end is the dialogue is sometimes a
little hard to catch there are times
when the
you know not really high up in the mix
so you really got him there was a couple
of times where I have to go to you and
say what already talking as a couple if
there's not much dialog there was a
couple of times I'm like way up a little
couple loss right now yeah and it's the
kind of story where even if you missed
up you can still grasp what's happening
but it does help and I think the time
things will make more sense this is
definitely a movie that I think takes to
I feel like he just makes those kind of
movies part of my like too and part of
what it's waged that lack of character
development I'd say is that every person
in this cast gets a great moment in the
movie yeah even dudes like Cillian
Murphy and some of the side characters
who aren't that huge are really
impactful when nothing is wasted when I
say like the TOA makes so unique is this
kind of felt like a hypnotic nightmare
okay yeah yeah and I mean you know a
movie will never give you the experience
of going to war but I did appreciate
this one for just putting you in there
with the people and watching the
struggle that's neither as glorious nor
as terrible in the same way you're
imagining I've never been in a situation
like that and I gotta imagine the
reality of it is a lot less glamorous
and a lot more kind of like this it's
just about people struggling on the
ground well yeah
right now we both really liked it before
watching on IMAX we'll probably love it
there's a record yeah well you guys see
dunker did you love it
their favorite Christopher Nolan film
the whole time do you prefer Dover
hacksaw bridge I want to see that
that movie is special her good plenty of
character that I believe Scott Reil
rejects click that notification valve
yeah John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of blunt
house and check out all our exclusive
personal awards over at patreon.com
slash the real rejects